Max Ross: Good afternoon, everybody. Thanks
for coming.
Let's go ahead and get started.
My name is Max Ross, and today we're going
to be talking about testing techniques for
Google App Engine.
Quick reminder -- you can follow along with
some live notes that are being taken on this
wave here.
Give you all a second to type that in. [pause]
We have a moderator module there.
So you can ask questions at the end.
Okay. So, a little bit about me.
I'm a software engineer at Google. I work
on the App Engine team.
I do things related to persistence -- I work
on the data store.
I work on the JPA and JDO implementations
that ship with the Java SDK.
I do various things related to the Java runtime.
The most important thing that you need to
know about me with respect to this talk, though,
is that -- I take testing very, very, very
seriously.
I love writing tests. Tests make me feel good.
They let me sleep well at night.
And I hope that makes you feel good knowing
that a storage guy on the App Engine team
feels this way.
Brief overview of what we're going to cover
-- I want to spend a few minutes talking
to you about developer testing in general.
And then, we're going to talk about some techniques
for testing your App Engine apps locally using
the App Engine SDK.
And then, we're going to get a little bit
more adventurous, and we're going to talk
about techniques for running your tests in
the Cloud.
And I've got some really, really cool demos
planned that I think you're going to like.
Then, we'll wrap things up, and then I'll
take any questions that you might have.
So let's start with developer testing.
I want to define a couple of terms that I'm
going to use over and over.
There's a lot of language around testing.
There's disagreements about the definitions
of these terms.
I want to give you my definitions so that,
when I talk about an integration test or a
unit test, you know what I'm talking about.
I apologize if you disagree with these.
A "unit test" -- we're testing something very
small, something very precise -- no external
dependencies.
Or, if there are external dependencies, we're
in complete control of them.
A classic example might be a string parsing
routine where all of the logic is included
in just that single function.
You want to make sure it does what you expect
it to do.
We can expand the scope a little bit to an
integration test, where we're testing the
interaction between components or maybe even
systems.
Classic example here -- writing tests that
talk to a database or a data store if you're
working on App Engine.
You want to issue a query -- or, really -- put
some data in the database, issue a query,
make sure you get back what you expect.
And I'm going to show you some live demos
of that in action.
And then, expanding the scope all the way
out, we have end-to-end testing where you're
driving your application through the public
API.
For App Engine, this means http.
Classic example here might be verifying the
authorization flow of your application where
you go to a particular URL.
You don't have permission to look at it.
An admin logs in. They give you permission
to look at it.
You visit it again. You see that the page
renders.
So, I need to get up on my soap box just for
a few minutes here and let you know why I
am so passionate about developer testing.
The obvious benefit here is, you write some
code, you've added some functionality.
Now, you want to make that sure it does what
it does.
You want to make sure it does what you expect
it to do.
You write a test. You test that code.
You check that code in along with the test.
It gives you a good feeling about the code
you've just written.
And that's important. And that's valuable.
But, for me, that's not even the most important
thing that developer testing gets you.
When you're just starting out on a project,
checking code in is not particularly risky,
because you're not at risk of breaking anything.
You haven't even built anything yet.
So that first check in?
You wrote a test to make sure that that first
check in does what you wanted it to do, and
you feel good about and you check it in.
But that second check in is a little bit riskier,
because there's existing code.
There's existing features.
There's users who have expectations of this
code now.
So that second check in, you're not only in
danger of getting the initial thing wrong,
you're in danger of breaking the first thing.
And the third check in is riskier, and the
fourth check in is riskier.
And now, we fast forward three years into
your project, and you've had 50 developers.
How can you actually feel safe about the changes
you're making when there's so much at stake
with every single check in.
It's actually terrifying, right?
But if you're writing tests along the way,
you're mitigating that risk.
Each check in is not riskier, because every
time you check in, you're adding some code
to your code base.
It's part of your code base that verifies
that what you just checked in does what you
wanted it to do.
And as long as you're running those tests
every step of the way, you never have to lose
that confidence.
So this makes me feel really good about my
code.
So the advice that I want to give to everybody
in the audience today -- if you're not already
doing testing, please, try it out.
See if it works for you. The benefits are
real.
This is a short-term investment in the success
of your project, but it's also -- more importantly
-- a long-term investment in the success
of your project.
Treat your code as first-class citizens in
your code base, right alongside the production
code. They deserve it.
I'm not the only one at Google who feels this
way.
Testing at Google has a long and proud history.
We take testing very, very seriously.
I've listed up here a couple of frameworks
that have come out of Google engineering that
are related to testing.
There's a number of C++ frameworks, which
are basically the C++ testing frameworks that
we use internally.
There's a couple of Java frameworks, one really
interesting one which is useful for concurrency
testing.
This is an example of how seriously we take
it that the tools we develop inside, we've
released an open source whenever we can.
We want everybody to have these same tools
at their disposal.
So, how does this relate to App Engine?
When we talk about App Engine and where our
code runs, we're typically talking about two
different execution environments.
There's the Cloud where our code actually
lives, serving requests on the Internet.
And then there's the dev app server, which
is running locally, which gives us the same
functionality that we have in the Cloud, but
not the same scale.
There's actually a third environment that
we pretty much never talk about, but we should
-- and that's what we're talking about here
today.
It's the test execution environment.
The test execution environment can exist locally,
and it can exist in the Cloud.
It can be serving http requests, but -- more
interestingly for the purposes of this talk
-- it can also involve a test harness issuing
requests to very precise pieces of your code.
So the question is, do we need App Engine
specific testing strategies?
And the answer is, "Yes, we do need some."
And that's what we're going to go over.
So, let's start with "locally," because this
is a little bit more familiar.
How many people here have written an App Engine
application and written some tests that run
locally?
Okay. I'm very happy to see all those hands.
Good.
Hopefully those of you who raised your hands
will agree with me that a lot of it is the
same.
Your frameworks apply -- JUnit, PyUnit -- you
want to write Selenium tests.
These things work. There's not a whole lot
that's different.
The best practices make sense as well -- in
terms of isolation, in terms of how you're
going to design your application so that it
can be tested, in terms of how you're going
to write your tests so that they're effective
and isolated and not flaky.
This is all really good news.
What's different? Not a lot, but there are
some interesting technical details that I
want to get into.
The main one is that the RPC layer that's
part of App Engine that dispatches all of
your calls to back end services has assumptions
about the environment that it executes in.
So I've got an example up here that I've taken
from the implementation of the data store
API.
And you can see this call API proxy dot get
current environment -- if it's not there,
it throws a null pointer exception.
The data store API assumes that either the
dev app server or the application server that's
running in production is setting up a current
environment for it.
And if it's not there, it's going to throw
an exception.
But so, what happens when you're running a
unit test or an integration test and there's
no dev app server to set this environment
up -- you're going to get this exception -- the
null pointer exception.
So what are you going to do?
Well, if you've been writing unit tests on
App Engine for a while, you probably remember
originally you had to jump through a bunch
of hoops to make this work.
You had to implement a bunch of interfaces
that sort of seemed like they were part of
the implementation, and it was just dirty
and messy.
And then, a couple releases ago, we released
the App Engine testing APIs, which make this
much, much, much nicer.
So I want to show you a quick demo of using
the App Engine testing APIs locally.
And we're going to go back to our favorite
little App Engine demo app -- the Guestbook.
And we're going to write an integration test
for Guestbook.
Oops. Not ready for that yet.
Okay. So this is not your typical guestbook
application.
It looks the same. You've got your shout-outs.
But the interesting thing about it -- actually,
let me show you that application real quick.
[pause]
While that comes up -- The interesting thing
about this version of the Guestbook application
is that it supports higher availability rights.
So when you give it a new message, it will
try to write it to the data store.
And if that "put into the data store" succeeds,
then everything is good.
But if it fails, it's going to queue it up
in a task queue task to execute later.
So we got eventual consistency with our data
store rights.
Now, I want to write an integration test that
verifies that this works the way that I expect.
So I'm going to write two tests here using
the local testing APIs.
The first one is going to test that synchronous
rights behave the way I expect.
The second one is going to verify that asynchronous
rights work the way I expect.
Let's get a little screen real estate here.
So I'm a little bit old-school. I use Junit3.
So I'm going to extend test case.
And the very first thing I'm going to do is
make sure that I've got the App Engine testing
APIs configured properly.
So I'm going to get a local service test helper.
I'm going to instantiate that, and since this
test uses the local data store service and
the local task queue service, I'm going to
instantiate some configs for both of those
to tell the test helper that I want to use
both of those local services.
That's the one for the data store.
Okay. So I've got that allocated.
And now, I need to override my set up and
tear down methods to make sure that the helper
gets set up and tear down as well. [pause]
There's the set up. Tear it down. Symmetry
is good.
Okay. I'm ready to write some tests.
There's a couple of helper objects that I
think I'm going to need.
I'm testing a Guestbook DAO -- Data Access
Object.
So let's get a hold of one of those.
And we'll get a hold of a data store service
as well because I'm going to use the low-level
data store API for some of my assertions.
[pause] Okay. I'm ready to go.
Got my object set up.
So the first test is going to be testing synchronous
rights.
Signature of this method is "DAO save."
I need a greeting object.
So I'm going to rely on the helper method
that I have sitting around. [pause]
And we'll save that.
And if we look at the implementation of this
method, you can see that one of the things
that I'm doing here is setting the key back
on the greeting once I've saved it.
This is the indication to the presentation
layer that this was a synchronous right.
Because I got a key back. I got a unique ID
back.
So let's verify that I got a key. [Pause]
"AssertNotNull" And let's also make some assertions
that the data actually found its way into
the data store.
So I'm going to use the low-level API to look
this thing back up.
Data store service dot get greeting. Look
it up by its key.
Now, this will throw an exception if it's
not found -- "entity not found" exception.
That's fine. I want this test to fail if it's
not found.
So I'm not going to bother catching this exception.
I'm just going to let it propagate out.
And then, finally, I'll assert that the content
is what I expect.
Okay. This looks like a reasonable test to
me.
I think I could sleep at night.
There's probably a couple extra things that
I would do if I wasn't typing it live in front
of all of you, but let's see if it's green.
Okay, it's green. I'm happy about that.
But let's try the more interesting example
-- the asynchronous rights.
In order to test that asynchronous rights
are working, I need to force the data store
to fail.
The way I'm going to force the data store
to fail is, I'm going to create a custom delegate
object.
A "delegate object" is an object that all
of your RPCs pass through en route to the
back end services -- whether you're running
in production or whether you're running locally.
So, in this case, I'm going to create a custom
delegate object that will throw an exception
on every data store RPC.
So I'm going to call this an "explosive delegate,"
and it's going to extend "base delegate,"
which is a helper class that I've defined.
There's not a lot going on in here.
It's really just delegating for all of the
methods.
Just trying to save some typing.
The one method I want to override is make
synchronous call, because I am making an asynchronous
call to the data store, and I want to intercept
that.
I want to see that -- if the package is data
store v3 -- this is a constant that is defined.
So it's not -- it's sort of a magic value,
but it's a publicly accessible magic value
-- it's accessible to everyone here.
If it's a data store call, I'm going to throw
an API proxy exception with a specific error
code, which I want to import.
Internal error. Okay.
That line's a little bit long. We can split
that up.
So any data store call that comes through
here is going to generate an exception.
The next thing I want to do is intercept all
the calls to the task queue.
The reason I want to do this is because I'm
going to capture the message that I'm sending
to the task queue so I can make some assertions
about it.
So I need to declare a member so I have a
place to put it when I actually catch it.
And so, this is a bulk add request.
And when it's a task queue message, I'm going
to merge that -- I'm going to populate that
value.
These are protocol buffers.
So, I'm just going to take the raw bytes and
fold them in.
And then, I'm going to let the call flow through.
So I've got a custom delegate here, which
I can use to assert that, when the data store
throws an exception, I then get a task queue
message.
And I'm going to capture that task queue message.
And then, I'm going to make some assertions
on it.
So let's write the actual test that installs
this delegate.
The first thing I need is an instance of this
delegate.
And then, I'm going to install it.
This install method is something that's in
that base class that I didn't want to type
out in front of everybody, but it's two lines
of code.
It's just setting a global variable holding
on to the original value.
And I know I'm going to want to un-set it
later so that my test doesn't leave a weird
state around.
So I'm going to do all of this in a "finally"
block. [pause] Uninstall.
And then, we're going to do something very
similar to the original test. [pause]
Except, instead of asserting that the key
is not null, I'm going to assert that the
key is null.
Because this is the indication to the presentation
layer that this was an asynchronous right.
So that it can display something appropriate
like, "We got your message.
It'll be there shortly."
And then, finally, I want to make assertions
about the greeting that is actually encoded
in the task queue message.
And I have a helper function for that that's
going to help me with that.
I've got my greeting.
And I can say, "Demo Helper, please extract
the greeting from this task queue message."
Okay. Yes? No? [pause]
Oh, I forgot to make it a member. There we
go.
Okay. So, now I have something that's checking
that there is no key at the conclusion of
the right and also checking that the greeting
gets properly encoded in the task.
And again, I've got to test the passes.
And I feel reasonably good about this.
This is pretty decent test coverage for this.
Ordinarily, I'd probably want to verify the
individual attributes of the greeting to make
sure that they got translated properly, but
for live demo purposes, I'm satisfied with
this.
So let's move on.
That was the local testing API.
What I hope you notice was that I did a little
bit of set up at the beginning to install
the test helper.
And then, everything else was pretty standard
unit testing integration type stuff with a
little bit of extra knowledge of how the RPC
layers work.
So let's move on to the fancier stuff.
Do you want to run your tests in the Cloud?
I want to run my tests in the Cloud.
I want to run my tests in an environment that
is as realistic as possible.
And we've done a really good job making sure
that the dev app server has equivalent functionality,
but there is no substitute for the real thing
functionality-wise -- also performance-wise,
right?
The local data store service stores everything
in memory.
You're not going to get accurate latencies
for writes and reads unless you're running
things in production.
So, fidelity is really an important reason
to run your tests in the Cloud.
The other reason, though, is efficiency.
If you've got a really large test suite, Google
App Engine has all of these computing resources
that are at your disposal.
So rather than sitting there waiting for your
test suite to run for 30 minutes or an hour,
or however long it's going to take -- or,
biting the bullet and deciding to set up your
own test grid which you are then going to
need to maintain -- upload your test to App
Engine. Run them there.
We will manage your test grid for you.
So what are the similarities between the types
of testing that you're used to doing and Cloud
testing? Again, your frameworks work.
Your best practices work.
End to end testing -- in this case, we're
just driving things through the front end
of your application.
The front end of your application is available
on App Engine the same way the front end of
your application is available when you're
running locally.
So that's the same.
Again, this is really good news.
What's different? There are more differences
here.
First and foremost, your tests are now subject
to the requirements we have for App Engine
requests -- which means, they need to finish
in 30 seconds, they have to obey the sandbox
restrictions.
So, if you have tests that like to communicate
directly with the network or spin up threads
or do any of the other things that we don't
let you do in the Cloud, that's going to pose
a problem.
Now, I don't have any good solutions for those
two issues.
Your tests still need to finish in 30 seconds,
and they still need to obey the sandbox restrictions.
But this third one here -- that you have to
invoke your tests over http -- I do have a
good solution for you here. [pause]
I have a framework called GAE Cloud Cover,
and it just went 1.00 final last night.
And now, it's at 1.01 final, because I found
a bug this morning, but I'm releasing it.
And its sole purpose is to help with this
issue -- How are you going to run your unit
tests and your integration tests over http?
Test harnesses typically assume that they
can communicate with your code in process,
but when they get to the Cloud, that's no
longer possible.
But Cloud Cover is going to help with this.
We're going to push your tests into the Cloud.
We're going to install Cloud Cover along with
it.
And through the Cloud Cover UI, we're going
to drive your tests.
So let me give you a demo that's going to
illustrate how easy it is to take the test
suite that we just built and deploy it to
the Cloud.
The primary design goal of Cloud Cover is
to run existing test suites.
I don't want you to have to retrofit everything
that you've already done to run in this specific
environment.
I want your tests to run locally just as well
as they run in the Cloud and vice versa.
So if you want to get your tests running in
the Cloud, I've listed the steps here: You're
going to install a JAR.
I'm not going to show you how to do that.
You're going to configure a Servlet.
It's fairly boilerplate. The documentation
describes it nicely.
You are going to replace the local service
test helper with Cloud Cover's own implementation
of the local service test helper.
And the reason for that is that the local
service test helper that I showed you when
I was writing those tests assumes that you're
running locally with local services available.
But when you're running in the Cloud, those
local services aren't available.
So we want to install Cloud Cover's version
of this, which is really going to turn those
initialization steps into no ops.
Because everything that you already need in
production is there.
You don't need to set up that current environment.
You don't need to mess with the data store.
Then, we're going to write one small class,
which is going to tell Cloud Cover about the
test suite that it's going to run.
We're going to deploy, we're going to run,
and we're going to feel good.
Oops. Before we get to that, let me show you
the demo.
So, what do you think, Alon? Live or offline?
Go for it? Let's see what happens.
So, I have this very simple demo queued up
here.
This is the Cloud Cover UI.
I'm going to click "start new run" and looking
good.
Okay. So it ran extremely fast.
There are only three tests here, and it shows
a failure.
Ooh, and I got a little XMPP message saying,
"Hey, your test run is done" -- which is not
that useful when it takes five seconds, but
if it takes an hour, that's nice.
And, this happened to fail because I included
-- intentionally -- a failure message, just
to show you what a failure looks like.
But, these are the tests that we just wrote.
And I uploaded them before I came up here.
So Test Async write succeeded. Test Sync Write
succeeded.
And this is sort of a poor man's version of
what a testing UI looks like in your IDE or
something like that.
But it's on the web.
Now, there's something interesting going on
here, though.
I've seen at least two other web test runners,
which appear to do something similar.
And some of them are really gorgeous.
They have these unbelievably pretty UIs.
One of them is called Kotori JUnit Web Runner.
And I just found out about it this week, and
I need to talk to that developer to see if
we can collaborate, because their UI is absolutely
gorgeous.
There's a link to it that should be in the
live wave when we're finished.
But Cloud Cover's doing something a little
bit different.
We're running your tests in parallel using
the task queue.
We're creating one task queue task per test.
And then, we're letting the workers run through
them.
So, here's an example of what's going on.
When I click that "create new run" button,
the tests are loading up in the suite.
The tests are being fed into the task queue.
And then, once they're all fed in, the workers
start chewing on them.
And this is all asynchronous, which means
we can do things in parallel.
And when we're done, we get that nice little
XMPP notification or e-mail or however you
want to get your notification -- you can configure
it, and you get the results of your test suite.
[pause]
There are some additional things we need to
think about when we want to run our tests
in the Cloud. Isolation.
How many people have ever run an existing
unit test suite where the tests run in parallel?
Googlers, right?
Because we have a framework that does it for
us.
Okay. Not a Googler?
Good. Okay. Great.
So, it gets more complicated, right?
Your tests are now interacting with one another
in ways that you didn't expect.
So this first example up here -- let's say
we have two tests -- one which deals with
a "read through cache," which, when you ask
it for a value, if the value isn't there,
it then turns around and asks the data store
for it.
And then, you have some other tests, which
is just a simple query, right?
Feed some data into the data store, issue
a query, make sure what you got back is what
you expect.
You wouldn't expect there to be any interesting
interactions, but if we wrote that explosive
delegate that I showed you in the earlier
example, and we installed that, that explosive
delegate is global, which means that, if these
two tests happen to hit these two same points
at the same time, the test that's just verifying
the simple query is going to blow up, because
it's going to try to do something that talks
to the data store, and that explosive delegate
is sitting there.
And it's going to throw an exception, and
you're going to scratch your head thinking,
"What went wrong? This didn't happen last
time."
And now, you've got flaky tests.
Another example that we need to think about
here is that your test data needs to be "thread
safe" -- and I put that in quotes.
And these examples here -- we might have one
test that creates a user, another test that
deletes a user.
And if they get to these two points at the
same time where the creation test is asserting
that something exists after the deletion test
has gone ahead and done its deletion.
Again, we're going to get a test failure in
a way that we didn't expect, right?
We're looking at test create user, and it
failed -- and we said -- "Well, we created
it. And then, we tried to read it back, and
it's telling me it's not here -- what happened?"
Well, this other test deleted the data out
from under you.
So non-thread safety gives you flakiness,
and flakiness can be really frustrating because
it's difficult to reproduce.
And even if you do reproduce it, you might
not reproduce it in the exact same way.
So we need solutions to these problems.
Here are the solutions to these problems.
These are both part of Cloud Cover.
For the delegates, we have an alternate delegate
implementation that you will need to retrofit
your tests with.
It's a thread-safe delegate.
So the example that I showed you at the beginning
-- instead of installing that delegate globally,
we will use a thread safe delegate so that
that change will only be visible to the thread
that needs it.
That's going to take care of it there.
We do have to make that change to our code,
but it's a pretty minor change.
The other solution is very cool.
We have a feature coming out shortly -- if
not in the next SDK, then probably the one
after -- called "Name Spaces."
And this is a way to stripe your data.
This is a way to scope your data.
So that you can perform some work within a
certain name space.
And the work that you're doing with, say,
the data store or mem cache -- all of that
persistent state is associated with that name
space.
So we can isolate the data of different tests
from one another.
And this is exactly what Cloud Cover does
-- every single test that's running has its
own name space.
So in the example that I showed you before
-- when we say that we are creating a user
and then deleting a user, and some other test
is creating a user and then verifying that
it exists.
Even if, from the application's point of view,
those entities are identical, they're not
going to overlap.
So, we've got our data isolation, and Cloud
Cover is going to take care of this for you.
Thank you.
So, let me show you an example of this actually
working.
The demo that I showed you before -- that
was a talk demo.
It was very small.
But I want to show you something real.
And I figured, "What better way to show you
that this is real than to run a real test
suite in the Cloud using Cloud Cover?" So
I've taken the test suite for the JDO/JPA
Implementation that ships as part of the Java
SDK.
It's about 1300 unit and integration tests.
And it does all of the hairy stuff you might
ever imagine a test suite could do with the
local data store.
Every type of query you can think of -- installing
custom delegates left and right -- this test
suite does it.
And so, that's what I'm going to run here.
I will select it from my drop down.
This test suite is called "data nucleus,"
because the test suite is built on the data
nucleus access platform.
And I will start this running.
This will not run as fast as the test that
I just showed you.
I'm running half the test suite, because I
do want this to finish while I'm still up
here.
It does take some time.
This is an example of testing in the Cloud
for fidelity as opposed to efficiency.
Almost all of these tests are doing lots and
lots and lots of data store interaction.
Locally, it will run faster, because the local
data store is completely in memory.
It will run slower here, because it's using
the real data store.
It's actually communicating with the back
end data store.
But, I do get the true experience of running
this code in the Cloud.
So this is the test suite that we run before
we release a new implementation of the JDO
and the JPA.
And, as we can see here, it's going along
pretty well, actually.
It's at 34 percent.
You'll notice that there's this item here
-- "too slow."
There's 148 tests that are too slow.
These are the tests that aren't finishing
in 30 seconds.
At some point, I need to decide whether I
want to break these tests up just so that
they pass on Cloud Cover.
I might do it, because I really, really would
like to run this in Cloud Cover and see all
green.
I haven't seen it yet.
There are still a few interactions that I
haven't sorted out.
But, by and large, this is working. You can
see it clicking away.
We've got 68 tests that are running in parallel
right now.
Let me show you in the admin console -- maybe
-- what's going on behind the scenes.
C'mon.
Yes! All right.
So we can see our traffic spiked up a little
bit.
But all of the real work is happening in the
task queues.
You can see we've got 32 tasks in the queue.
We've run 1200 tasks in the last minute.
And I can look in here, and you can see that
there is one task for every high-level test
case that I'm executing.
And so, the workers are just clicking their
way through.
I configured my default queue to have the
maximum rate, because I want to get through
these as quickly as possible.
The maximum rate is 50 tasks per second.
These tests aren't that fast.
So I'm not actually scratching that limit.
But, I'm going to show you something in a
little bit that definitely makes use of that.
So, let's go back -- let's see how we're doing
here.
We're 93 percent done. We're just about finished.
Yep, there it is. Okay, cool. [pause]
So, that was the fancy demo.
And that should convince you that this is
real.
That really is the real test suite doing all
sorts of hairy unit and integration testing
stuff with App Engine running in the Cloud.
And it ran still pretty quickly even though
it was using the real data store.
But let's take this a little bit further.
Everything I've shown you so far has involved
running App Engine test suites in the Cloud.
But why limit ourselves?
The Cloud Cover framework is agnostic.
It doesn't care whether or not your code under
test uses App Engine.
It doesn't care whether you're using JUnit
or TestNG or which version of J Unit.
It's a little bit of work you have to do to
plug in a different test harness, but the
framework itself is agnostic.
So if you have a large test suite -- even
if it's a test suite for something that is
not App Engine, why not upload it and let
App Engine be your grid?
So, let's do an arbitrary demo -- arbitrary
code -- the Google Collections Framework.
If you're a Java developer and you're not
familiar with the Google Collections Framework,
check it out.
It's really, really useful. That's the end
of the plug.
This is data structures, okay? It has nothing
to do with web apps.
It doesn't know anything about the data store.
It was built long before App Engine ever existed.
These guys have 44,000 tests.
I'm not going to run 44,000 tests.
I can't get 44,000 tasks into the task queue
in 30 seconds.
If I could, I would go for it.
But I am going to run a bunch of these tests.
These tests have absolutely nothing to do
with App Engine.
So I have uploaded that test suite.
This is the Google Collections test suite.
And I'm going to start the run.
Now, this initial request is slow.
This library does a lot of dynamic test generation.
It's working really hard.
These folks didn't actually write 44,000 tests
by hand.
They have a number of template tests, which
they're using for different map implementations
and different list implementations.
And they have ways of generating tests for
the different implementations of map and list
that they're providing over and over again.
So they kind of exploded out.
But I'm running -- I think -- 2400 tests here?
And this is humming along very nicely. I've
already finished 1500.
This thing's going to be done very quickly.
I've got a failure -- the supplier's test.
Let's see what's going on there.
Oh, it's already done.
Okay. That was fast.
I look at this failure, and look what's failing
-- "Test Thread Safe."
Well, that shouldn't be too much of a surprise,
right?
I told you up front that, if you're going
to run your tests in the Cloud, your tests
in the code under tests have to abide by the
restrictions of App Engine.
Here's a thread safety test.
They're spinning up threads.
I can't run this test on Cloud Cover. [pause]
But, this work will get done -- we will take
care of it on the Python side.
We need to hone in on what the exact expectations
of Python developers are.
Running tests inside the local sandbox -- this
is kind of a big one.
Those tests that I showed you -- those integration
tests that I was running locally -- weren't
running with any of the security restrictions
enabled.
I could have written -- I'm sorry -- if the
code that I was testing did something that
wouldn't run in App Engine like spin up a
thread, those tests still would have passed.
It wasn't running in the secure JVM; it was
running in a raw JVM.
So we need to figure out how to do this.
We want as much fidelity as possible, whether
you're running in the Cloud or locally.
And part of making it a proper emulation is
enforcing the security constraints when you're
running your application in the dev app server.
We've got that working.
But when you're testing -- we don't have that
working yet.
I tried to do it in time for this demo -- couldn't
do it.
It's hard. We need to figure some stuff out.
So we'll get to that.
And then, there are certain types of tests
where you want to launch the actual dev app
server and throw some traffic at it.
Or, in the case of the integration test that
I showed you when we were trying to figure
out what happened with the task queue, and
we were extracting that greeting object from
the task queue.
You might have been looking at that and thinking,
"Well, rather than asserting on this sort
of -- these low-level bytes that are passing
through the RPC layer, why don't you just
pause for a bit and wait for the task to execute?
The reason is we're not in a good position
to actually write that test yet.
The local task queue implementation uses the
URL fetch service, right?
That's how tasks work in App Engine is you
give it a URL to hit.
But in order to hit a URL, you need to have
an http server running, and we don't have
that yet.
So we need to find a way to make that much
easier to do so that you can write those types
of tests in the most natural way.
For Cloud Cover, there's lots of really interesting
work to be done here, and I think we're just
getting started.
And the cool thing is that it's completely
open source.
There should be a link on the live wave -- if
not now, then shortly -- that shows you where
you can download it.
And if anybody wants to help out with this,
I've already got a bunch of feature requests
filed.
If you've got your own ideas for what it should
look like -- that would be cool.
If you want to make the UI look as beautiful
as that other one that I referenced before,
that would be cool.
Jump in. [pause]
So, the conclusions that I want to take -- that
I hope -- that I want you to take away.
First and foremost -- developer testing is
important.
If you didn't believe that coming in here,
I hope I've convinced you to at least take
a good look at it.
Mitigating that risk as your project grows
can really, really make a big difference in
the long run.
The other thing I hope you see is that everything
that you already know about testing transfers
to App Engine.
This isn't the case where you need to unlearn
things and learn a totally different skill
set.
If you know how to write testable apps already,
you know how to write testable apps on App
Engine.
If you know how to write effective tests already,
you know how to write effective apps on App
Engine.
You just need to become familiar with a couple
of the technical details that are specific
to App Engine.
When it comes to local testing, use the App
Engine testing API.
It's going to make your life much easier.
And when it's time to run your tests in the
Cloud, use Cloud Cover, push your tests inside
the Cloud, and let Cloud Cover drive it.
Finally, remember that -- even if you're not
a web application developer, you can still
use App Engine.
App Engine is good at fan out.
It's not a general-purpose computing platform,
but it's really good at web applications,
and it's really good at fan out.
And if there is a fan out element to what
you're doing, like with testing -- there's
a test suite.
It's made up of individual tests.
They don't know anything about one another.
They're not related to one another.
That type of problem can be very effectively
solved by App Engine.
So keep your minds open. And now, let's do
some questions.
Okay. And feel free to ask live questions
as well. [chuckling]
So, the number one question on moderator -- I'll
get to you in just one second - the number
one question on moderator was, "Is this talk
Java specific?
I hope not." Conceptually, this all applies,
right?
If you want to write Cloud Cover for Python,
you could do it today -- except for the aspect
of the name spaces not being available yet.
But you can write all of the code.
It just won't necessarily run if you're using
the data store or mem cache.
So apologies to anyone in here who felt misled.
Let's take a live question here.
Q [first male audience member] Challenges
with data-driven testing -- one challenge
is isolation.
The second challenge is the data set up proof.
You have proofs like DB what's -- how do you
do that in App Engine?
Max Ross: You were asking the hard questions
at the fireside chat yesterday too, right?
Okay. [pause]
My personal approach is -- for unit and integration
tests, I try to operate on a fairly limited
data set that I can set up easily within the
30-second limit.
I'm not uploading megabytes and megabytes
of data that I then assume the existence of
across multiple tests.
I've been on projects where we did that before.
We ultimately moved away from it, because
you will find yourself in the position where
you need to restore that data to its original
state.
Or you find yourself in the position of pretending
to commit transactions and then rolling them
back, but things sometimes fail when you commit
-- you miss out on opportunities to see those
errors.
So, my approach is, try to write tests that
operate on limited data sets.
I know that's not always practical.
If you find yourself in a position where you
do need a large data set, testing that in
the Cloud -- right now that's going to be
a challenge.
But, very good question. Yes.
Q [second male audience member] I notice you
didn't use Dependency Injection. What's your
take on Dependency Injection?
Max Ross: I love Dependency Injection.
If -- I've used Guice a lot. I've used Spring
a little bit.
We don't do it as part of the SDK, because
we don't want to force any frameworks on you.
We want you to bring your own frameworks.
So, in that particular data access object,
perhaps you caught that I was initializing
private final members in line.
And that would be a smell in my own code.
But in terms of keeping things short for a
demo, that's the way I initialized it.
But, in general -- I should back up and say
-- I don't think Dependency Injection is
necessarily important.
I think inversion of control is important.
And Dependency Injection, I think, is a very
effective way to get inversion of control.
Didn't want to introduce any additional frameworks
here.
And just, as a team, our general approach
is, we want to let you choose the frameworks
that you want to use.
So that's why you don't see Guice as part
of the SDK or Spring as part of the SDK.
That's your choice. We don't want to force
that on you.
Okay. Let's see what else we have on moderator.
Q [Max Ross reads question from moderator]
Any integrations with C?
Continuous integrations with servers like
Hudson for testing monitoring?
Max Ross: So, this is -- so no. But, all of
this can totally happen.
This -- Cloud Cover is -- it's not nearly
as full-featured.
But the idea is very similar to something
that we have running internally at Google
that we use to run our tests.
And, in addition to running all of our tests,
we have data repositories that keep track
of the history of our test runs.
We've got all sorts of good analytical data.
So, all of this could happen with Cloud Cover.
I can't think of any reason why Cloud Cover
can't be the external version of this thing
that we have running internally, which is
incredibly useful in terms of integration
with IDEs -- integration with other servers,
reporting metrics -- all of these things.
You could even imagine going so far as to
have an online performance regression framework,
which would be incredibly useful.
That sort of thing is so difficult to set
up, but so valuable once you have it.
So. The answer to the specific question, "No,
that integration doesn't exist."
But I think all of these things are possible,
and I would love to talk with anybody who's
interested in pushing it in that direction.
Live question.
Q [third male audience member] Hi. Is the
App Engine testing API also Java-specific?
Max Ross: The App Engine testing API is currently
Java only.
And that is the thing that I want to rectify.
Q [third male audience member] Because we'd
love to have Python --
Max Ross: Yeah, I mean you can -- don't get
me wrong -- you can write tests for Python.
It's just these libraries wrap up sort of
some of the messiness. Yes.
Q [fourth male audience member] Hi. If I have
to execute a heavy multiple sweat test -- stress
test.
So, should I let Google know beforehand?
Max Ross: So if your test is similar.
If your test is a load test, then -- we have
-- in fact there was an IO talk two years
ago -- which should still be online -- by
a fellow named Ken Ashcraft who talks about
load testing strategies for Google App Engine.
So, the general piece of advice is, ramp up
slowly.
Don't turn your traffic on like a brick wall,
right?
If you look at your admin console, it should
ramp up as opposed to just being a giant step.
And beyond that, I would recommend looking
at that talk.
There's very useful strategies there.
Q [fourth male audience member] So is there
any cap or?
Max Ross: Well, it's just traffic to us, right?
It's just traffic to us.
So we don't -- we can't distinguish between
a load test and traffic.
It's just -- if your app's getting traffic,
we don't know what you're doing.
Enable billing -- that will help.
Yeah, thank you. Yes.
Q [fifth male audience member] Thanks for
your talk.
So I've been running tests in parallel, in
sort of a cloudlike environment, for about
eight years, so it's good to see other folks
doing that in App Engine now.
Max Ross: Excellent.
Q [fifth male audience member] You said you
wanted to take tests that run fine locally
and then parellelize them. It seems like you
have to make a bunch of changes to them. There's
this delegate thing and this Junit3 config
thing so does that mean once you've done that
they no longer run locally or - 'cause you
really want both modes.
Max Ross: Right. So, the changes that you
have to make and -- let me just show you,
because I skipped over this part of my demo,
because I was working on time.
So, to answer your question, "Once you make
these changes, do they still run locally?"
"Yes, they absolutely run locally."
These Cloud Cover implementations of these
classes that you're swapping things out for
can distinguish between a local run and a
Cloud run.
So if you're running locally, they do the
thing that they normally do.
And then, if they're running in the Cloud,
then they do this slightly different behavior.
So, for this test that I wrote here, which
was the Guestbook DAO test,
there are two changes. Here's the first one.
[pause]
Okay. That's the first one.
Which, and, you know, if this were in the
-- for example in the JDO/JPA test suite,
this helper set up is in one base class that
everything extends.
So I didn't have to go through and change
it in 300 different places.
The other thing that you have to do is, change
the delegate.
And that's in this base class down here.
Where's "install?"
Okay. And in this case -- I didn't rehearse
this part so I have to find my way through
it.
But, it is the Cloud Cover local service test
helper.
Set delegate. Actually, so the first thing
we do here is, we're gonna replace that.
We're going to replace that. And that's it.
That's really it.
So, it's still pretty compatible.
It is true that your test suite is going to
have a dependency on Cloud Cover.
It's a really small JAR.
I don't think it's really going to get in
your way.
Does that answer your question? Yes.
Q [sixth male audience member] Are there any
Selenium style test suites coming for Visualization?
Max Ross: For Visualization -- I don't think
I understand.
I'm sorry. I know Selenium.
Q [sixth male audience member] I'm sorry,
for UI testing. It's a related question.
Max Ross: Okay, okay, okay.
I think it ties into the thing we want to
make better where we want to simplify the
process of running tests that fire up the
dev app server.
That will make that sort of testing easier.
When it comes to running these tests in production,
Selenium just wants to know what URL to hit,
right?
Q [sixth male audience member] You can actually
test click through scenarios with Selenium.
I was wondering if Google was going to release
anything that's App Engine specific, so that
we could test UI in Visualization on App Engine.
Max Ross: We don't have any concrete plans,
but let's talk for a minute afterwards, because
I have a feeling that I'm not fully grasping.
Q [seventh male audience member] I have a
very similar question.
Max Ross: Sure.
Q [seventh male audience member] Is there
any plans to -- is anybody building a load
testing kind of application on App Engine
which can do fan out?
Like bus computing and --
Max Ross: Where the load is generated by App
Engine?
Q [seventh male audience member] App Engine
and perhaps just something.
I mean, I'm sure that you have a lot of applications
which run on Webscape.
Max Ross: I'm not aware of anybody building
that.
Could be interesting.
I could take another question from moderator.
Q [Max Ross reads question from moderator]
Will testing.API be available for a modern
language?
Max Ross: Ouch. If you consider Python a modern
language -- and I do -- I don't want to start
any fights -- then, yes, it will be available.
It still hurts, though.
[audience laughs]
Q [eighth male audience member] Does local
memory data store persist collections using
helper, using JDO/JUnit? All my tests are
failing.
Max Ross: Sorry? All your tests are failing?
Q [eight male audience member] My collections
never come back.
Max Ross: Your collections never come back
when you're using JDO in your testing?
I'm sure I could help you diagnose it.
There is a blogpost that I'm planning for
my blog, which deals largely with recipes
for JDO and JPA.
And there is a testing entry long overdue.
So when that entry comes out, I'm going to
show you exactly how I do it.
The other thing you can do, though, is -- all
this test suite for JDO and JPA that I ran
using Cloud Cover is also completely open
source.
And you can download it, and you can type
"ant test," and it will run.
And so, you can see 1300 examples of testing
with JDO and JPA and there's lots and lots
of collections tests.
It's hard to get right. Yeah.
Q [ninth male audience member] Is the name
space feature you mentioned apply to the mem
cache service as well?
Max Ross: Yes. Data store and mem cache are
both name space aware.
I have not tested Cloud Cover with mem cache
tests yet.
I would not be shocked to find that I'm doing
something wrong.
But I will test it before this name space
feature becomes generally available to make
sure that, when you can use all of these features
in App Engine, you can also use all of these
features in Cloud Cover.
Max Ross: I think -- oh, there's one last
question here.
Q [Max Ross reads question from moderator]
Can you do isolated end to end testing on
the local GAE server?"
Max Ross: I'm not sure I know what is meant
by "isolated."
Is that referring to data set up and tear
down?
I don't know. Okay.
So thank you all for coming.
I really appreciate it.
>> [Applause]
Max Ross: And stay tuned for the next talk.
Alfred's going to be talking about next gen
queries, and it's really cool stuff.